Salut !
Vous pensez que la réalité qui
nous entoure n'est faite que de hasard
et de conséquences,
de choix individuels ?
Naïfs que vous êtes.
Vous pensez que la nature
se développe de manière aléatoire,
ou que vous êtes en train
de regarder une de mes vidéos,
là tout de suite de votre plein gré.
Bon ben moi aussi,
je pensais ça
avant de rencontrer un truc
qui s'appelle La loi de Benford.
Et là mon univers s'est
littéralement écroulé.
Nous ne sommes pas si libre
car la Loi de Benford prouve
que les chiffres aléatoires,
ne sont en fait pas un hasard.
Et ça a des répercussions partout,
même dans les vidéos YouTube.
Loïc, générique !
- Déjà, si je veux parce que
moi, j'ai un plein gré, okay ?
- Vous voyez ce que je vis ?
Tous les jours ça.
[Musique]
La loi de Benford démontre un ordre
dans le chaos des vues de YouTube.
Entre autres, parce qu'en vrai
YouTube, ça n'existait pas avant.
Si, je vous jure que c'est vrai.
Pour sponsoriser cette vidéo et
les gros projets comme matière grise.
On est déjà au
cinquième épisode
d'ailleurs, si vous les avez pas vu,
regardez les.
Cette vidéo ci est en partenariat
avec 'Rise of Kingdoms'
parce que dans ce jeu
il n'y a pas tellement de hasard.
Vous allez utiliser vos stratégies
pour changer l'histoire.
Imaginez que vous ayez le pouvoir
de construire la civilisation française.
Mais genre la meilleure version.
Bah arrêtez d'imaginer
et téléchargez 'Rise of kingdoms',
via mon lien ci-dessous.
Défendez la France et obtenez
un pack pour bien démarrer le jeu.
Au programme vous avez
la France, bien sûr.
Mais aussi dix autres royaumes
historiques avec leurs légendes,
Une unité spéciale,
un style d'architecture unique
et des bonus pour
chaque civilisation.
Et je vous avoue que
jouer Jeanne d'Arc
pour combattre
les anglais, c'est le feu.
Ma préférence dans le jeu,
c'est la stratégie entre
les différents types de terrains
qu'on combine avec la carte
qui est hyper détaillée.
Les forces et les faiblesses
de chaque unité.
Il y a un vrai bon moment à jouer,
puisque les batailles
sont en temps réel.
Et juste en faisant des
"Holdaine drague".
Je le dis bien Loïc ?
"Hold and drag".
- Ouais C'est pas mal.
- C'est l'accent ça.
Eh bien, juste en faisant des
Hold and drag sur les troupes.
Vous pouvez planifier
toute votre stratégie,
on a le contrôle total de la ville.
Même esthétiquement d'ailleurs.
Et apparemment ça plaît
pas mal puisque cher Loïc,
il y a quand même
50 millions de joueurs.
Et le jeu fait partie des 20
plus téléchargés
sur Apple et Google Play Store.
Vous pouvez donc télécharger
'Rise of Kingdoms' ici.
Vous obtenez le pack de démarrage,
le jeu est gratuit, c'est cool.
Et quand vous passez
par mon lien, n'oubliez jamais :
ça, ça soutient la chaîne,
donc ça aussi c'est cool.
Par contre autant dans le jeu
vous maîtrisez tout,
autant dans la vie, la loi de Benford
va mettre un uppercut au hasard.
On va faire une expérience très simple
mais complètement folle.
Prenez par exemple,
le nombre de vues de toutes
les vidéos YouTube d'une chaîne.
Disons un hasard, la mienne.
- La tienne, ouais.
- C'est le hasard.
Et en même temps, vous en profitez
pour vous abonner, activer la cloche.
Parce que tant qu'à faire,
je sais que vous l'avez pas fait,
donc faites le.
Et pour les vues de la chaîne,
je vais le faire moi-même,
rassurez-vous.
706 vidéos au moment
où j'écris cette vidéo.
Prenez maintenant le premier chiffre
de tous ces nombres.
Il y a toutes les vidéos, les 706.
Et il y a le nombre de vues à côté.
On prend le premier chiffre,
à chaque fois du nombre de vues
de chacune des 706 vidéos.
Par exemple, le premier chiffre
de celui-ci, c'est un 3.
Alors oui je sais, ça a pas l'air ouf,
la Loi de Benford pour le moment.
Mais vous allez voir
ce que ça rend à la fin.
Comptez maintenant
combien vous avez de un,
de deux, de trois, de quatre, de cinq,
de six, de sept et de huit et de neuf.
Attendez, avant de compter
dites-moi dans les commentaires
comment vous pensez,
que ces chiffres vont être répartis
sur mes 706 vidéos.
Est-ce qu'ils seront
tous autant présents ?
Est-ce qu'ils apparaîtront
toujours à la même fréquence ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un chiffre qui va
paraître plus souvent que les autres ?
Est-ce que les chiffres après le un
apparaîtront plus que
ceux avant le neuf ?
Faites-le vraiment, dites-moi
dans les commentaires
qu'est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on va avoir comme résultat.
D'ailleurs, il y a toutes les vidéos,
les 706.
Et il y a le nombre de vues à côté.
On prend le premier chiffre
à chaque fois,
du nombre de vues de chacune
des 706 vidéos.
Que je vais vous démontrer
dans quelques secondes.
Logiquement, votre cerveau
vous a dit que vous alliez trouver
à peu près la même quantité de un,
de deux, de trois, de quatre, etc.
Eh bien que nenni les amis.
Les résultats obtenus
sont les suivants :
30% de un,
17,1% de deux,
11,5% de trois,
9,6% de quatre,
8,5% de cinq,
7,9% de six,
5,7% de sept,
5,2% de huit
et 4,4% de neuf.
- Oui, ça c'est le hasard.
Je sais pas si tu prends
la chaîne de quelqu'un d'autre,
il y aura 4% de huit, 2% de un.
C'est le hasard !
- Okay, peut-être.
Effectivement, ces chiffres
sont clairement un pur hasard.
Mais si je vous dis maintenant
que vous obtiendrez
quasiment exactement
les mêmes pourcentages,
avec toutes les autres chaînes ?
A la condition évidemment que
vous preniez des chaînes YouTube
qui ont publié assez de vidéos
pour avoir un nombre conséquent,
pour avoir assez de
données à traiter.
- Ah ouais, donc
YouTube nous ment.
YouTube manipule les chiffres,
YouTube c'est...
Calme-toi Loïc.
Il s'agit en fait
de la Loi de Benford.
Aussi appelée la Loi
du premier chiffre significatif.
Elle est valable pour
énormément de choses.
Elle a d'abord été
découverte en 1880,
par un astronome, mathématicien,
économiste, statisticien américain,
d'origine Canadienne.
Oui, c'est déjà pas mal.
Et son nom c'est
Simon Newcomb.
Il explique dans un article de
l'American journal of Mathematics,
qu'il était en train de feuilleter
un livre de table logarithme.
On fait souvent ça.
Tu fais ça toi ?
- Lire un livre de table de logarithme ?
- Ouais, ouais,
bah on feuillette, on les lit pas,
comme lui feuillette.
Donc, lui aussi,
il était en train de feuilleter son livre
sur les tables de logarithme.
Quand il a fait la constatation
que les premières pages
étaient moins usées
que les suivantes.
Et encore que les suivantes
et encore que les suivantes.
En gros, la première était
moins usée que la deuxième,
qui était elle moins, moins usée
que la troisième, etc, etc.
Il a alors pris d'autres livres
et il a fait la même constatation.
- La quoi ?
- La constatation.
- La constation ?
C'est parce que comme
il était astronome
et qu'il voyait des constellations...
- Il rajoute des "tions"...
L'article reste
dans les oubliettes
jusqu'à ce que 57 ans
plus tard en 1938 ,
le physicien américain
Frank Benford
fasse exactement la même découverte
sans connaître le travail de Newcomb.
- C'est du plagiat ça !
- Et il colle son nom
à cette loi effectivement.
Après avoir collecté les premiers
chiffres de vingt série de nombres.
Il se rend compte que cette loi colle
non pas seulement avec les livres,
mais avec presque tous
les ensembles de données.
Les longueurs des rivières,
quel que soit l'unité
de mesure d'ailleurs,
en miles ou en kilomètres.
Les taux de mortalité, etc.
D'autres confirmations de cette loi
vont ensuite être données,
comme avec les profondeurs
des tremblements de terre
ou encore les cas
de maladies infectieuses.
Et cette Loi de Benford est si précise
que nous savons exactement
à quelle fréquence
apparaissent les chiffres.
Et ça ce n'est pas
si variable que ça.
En vrai c'est une grosse dinguerie.
Moi ça me rend fou.
Evidemment, il est quasiment
impossible de tomber pile poil
sur exactement les mêmes
pourcentages pour chaque chiffre.
Mais il est possible de
s'en approcher très fortement.
Et je vous le prouve si vous comparez
les pourcentages d'apparition
des chiffres que
je vous ai donné tout à l'heure,
quand on a analysé les vues
de ma chaîne YouTube.
Vous regardez les pourcentages,
vous les comparez
avec les pourcentages de référence
de la Loi de Benford.
C'est hyper troublant
mais c'est très très proche,
c'est quasiment exactement ça.
Par contre attention,
la loi ne fonctionne pas
avec absolument tout.
Par exemple ne tentez pas l'expérience
avec la taille des êtres humains.
Vous auriez la mauvaise surprise
de voir que le nombre 1
revient très très souvent.
C'est parce qu'on fait souvent
entre un mètre et deux mètres.
Ou que pour les pointures
des chaussures,
le neuf arrive pas
souvent en Europe.
Non il faut prendre
des vrais systèmes aléatoires.
Même chose pour les plaques
d'immatriculation des voitures du coup,
Les chiffres donnés aux véhicules
étant régulièrement répartis,
la Loi de Benford
elle fonctionne pas.
Ou la numérotation
des pages d'un livre,
évidemment là,
comme c'est un...
Il n'y a pas d'aléatoire.
S'il y a pas d'aléatoire,
il n'y a pas de Benford.
Il semblerait que la loi
se vérifie lorsque les nombres
des ensembles choisis varient
sur plusieurs ordres de grandeurs,
comme pour les communes.
Lesquelles peuvent voir
leur nombre d'habitants
constitués de quelques personnes
à plusieurs millions de personnes.
Et là ça fonctionne
quelle que soit la taille.
A quoi ça nous sert, cette info ?
Qu'est ce que la Loi de Benford
nous apporte au quotidien ?
Bah déjà, c'est assez ouf
de savoir ça,
donc ça a servi à faire une vidéo
sur ma chaîne YouTube là.
Donc ça c'est pas mal.
Mais ensuite il y a des personnes
qui se sont demandées :
Est-ce que la Loi de Benford
se vérifie toujours
si on change les nombres
d'un ensemble
sur lequel elle fonctionne de base ?
En gros si je modifie volontairement
les données récoltées,
est-ce que ça fonctionne toujours ?
Par exemple, si je trafiquais
les vues de ma chaîne ?
Eh bien la réponse est non.
Si vous ne connaissez pas
la Loi de Benford
et que vous changez plusieurs
des chiffres collectés,
de manière malhonnête.
Vous allez avoir tendance
à vouloir équilibrer inconsciemment
chacun des chiffres
de votre escroquerie.
Or la loi, elle s'appliquera plus
et on va voir des irrégularités
qui vont apparaître.
Surtout quand on fait
un graphique comparatif,
comme là avec
les données de référence.
Regardez les chiffres
de ma chaîne.
Cet escroc de Loïc
a falsifié les données
en gonflant un peu les gros chiffres,
pour voir ce que ça donnait.
ça fait diminuer
la proportion des petits
et le pourcentage d'apparition
de chaque chiffre a alors tendance
à s'éloigner des pourcentages
de la Loi de Benford.
Du coup c'est visible,
la courbe s'éloigne de ce à quoi
elle devrait ressembler au départ.
Il est donc possible de déceler
un ensemble de chiffres falsifiés,
à l'aide de cette loi.
Et qui donc a bien pu se dire
qu'il y avait un intérêt à utiliser ça ?
Bah les contrôleurs des impôts
et des fraudes évidemment.
Car oui ça fonctionne aussi
sur un cahier de compta
de Levallois par exemple.
Voilà, voilà.
Ils connaissaient pas
Benford apparemment.
Dans ce cas là, les impôts utilisent
la loi juste comme un outil indicateur,
pour voir s'ils peuvent déceler
une éventuelle fraude.
Et si ils voient ça, il y a une analyse
évidemment plus poussée
qui bien sûr, est effectuée ensuite.
Par la suite, pour voir si oui ou non
il y a eu fraude ou malversation.
Ou s'il s'agissait peut-être
d'une exception à la loi de Benford.
Un calcul a même
été créé pour connaître
le degré d'éloignement
de la loi de Benford acceptable,
afin de savoir si un ensemble
de nombres analysés
Doit être considéré
ou non comme suspect,
comme modifié,
comme trafiqué.
Mais y'a pas que là que ça sert.
En 2013, les votes aux élections
électorales du canton
de Genève en Suisse ont été
soumis à la loi de Benford
afin de voir si les résultats
étaient conformes à la loi.
Ce qui n'a pas été le cas et là
le test a été pris en compte
comme un indicateur
plus que comme un signal d'alarme.
Et la chancellerie
en a ensuite conclu,
en vérifiant que les résultats
étaient simplement inhabituels
mais qu'ils étaient okay.
Donc il n'y a eu aucun problème
à entacher le processus de vote.
Mais comme ça
ils ont pu jeter un œil.
Le monde de la science
s'est aussi penché sur le sujet,
notamment en analysant les nombres
publiés dans des articles scientifiques.
Afin de voir s'il y avait
d'éventuelles erreurs.
Encore plus fort,
en Espagne les volcanologues
Joan Marty et Adelina Geyer,
je crois que je prononce bien,
se sont également penchés
sur son utilisation de la loi
et l'ont testé sur leurs
bases de données.
Et ça fonctionne.
Et du coup si cette loi fonctionne
sur des événements aussi naturels
que des éruptions volcaniques,
ou des tremblements de terre.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
compléter à l'avance,
la suite de nombres
à analyser de manière
à ce que la Loi de Benford
continue à se vérifier.
Et qu'on puisse peut-être prédire
les futures catastrophes naturelles.
C'est une vraie question et certaines
personnes sont assez sceptiques
sur le côté mystique de cette loi.
Et ont tenté d'apporter une explication
un peu rationnelle à ce phénomène.
Nous comptons
à partir du chiffre un.
Logique.
Donc il serait tout à fait
aussi logique
qu'il soit le premier à apparaître
plus de fois que les autres.
Idem pour les chiffres suivants,
jusqu'au neuf,
qui lui est le dernier
à apparaître quand on compte
et qui apparaîtra donc logiquement
moins souvent que les autres.
30% de un, 17% de deux, etc.
Dans tous les cas,
ça n'empêchera pas de penser
que ce monde et cet univers
sont assez incroyables
dans leurs petits réglages sous-jacents,
quand on met le nez dedans.
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais personnellement
ça me retourne le cerveau de savoir
que des chiffres aussi improbables,
liés parfois à des décisions
totalement arbitraires en fait.
Ou à ce qu'on appelle
des hasards de la vie
ou encore simplement la nature,
le hasard de la nature.
Puisse être aussi correctement
rangés en catégories de pourcentages.
Merci encore également
à 'Rise of kingdoms'
d'avoir accepté ce partenariat.
N'oubliez pas de tester le jeu
en téléchargeant via
mon lien dans la description.
Et faites-vous une partie
pour voir par vous même.
C'est le meilleur argument.
Essayez vous-même c'est gratuit.
Bref comme toujours
je m'appelle Fabien Olicard,
ça ça va pas changer.
Abonnez-vous à cette chaîne
c'est gratuit.
Pensez à activer la cloche
si vous voulez voir passer
les prochaines vidéos.
N'hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo
si vous avez regardé jusqu'ici.
Ici, je vous mets une vidéo
sur un concours marrant
de calcul mental
qu'on avait fait.
Et ici une vidéo
sur le baromètre de Bohr.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !